make it into a closed sphere flatten it
into a patty
on a griddle and it's a delicious
delicious burger
hello and welcome to she doesn't read
the news with me
chris turner and me alice win
the long pause i thought you can
introduce i think it was because my
inflection made it sound like it was
only me with me chris turner in today's
news
and then that would be quite good sadly
alice has died if you can see her
she is an apparition a ghastly specter
well i do feel like i've been roped into
this
podcast every week when we record this i
have to drag her kicking and screaming
nails dragging
through the wood alice win i mean i
think the main story of this week
after asking how are you oh i'm good
thank you how are you
i'm very well thank you very polite
thank you for reciprocating
we watched the the classic
ben hur ben hur
what a film so do you guys realize that
ben hur is just about jesus
so the book it is based on was a huge
bestseller it outsold uncle tom's cabin
by harry by the way
that's mental because uncle tom's cabin
sold so many copies
and do you want to know a creepy fact
about uncle tom's cabin yes go ahead
um so uncle tom's cabin um you know at
the time
very anti i mean like it seems a bit
racist now obviously but um
at the time very anti-racist but for
people who don't know uncle tom's cabin
because i've never read it yeah
uh you know i might pretend to have read
it to make myself i think a lot of
people can
pretend to have read uncle i think a lot
of people pretend to have read most
books it's true
the sheer number of times people will
mention a movie and i'll be like oh yeah
and then they'll say you know that bit
and i'm just like why did i even say
that i've not seen that movie there's
nothing wrong with saying you haven't
seen the godfather
i haven't seen the godfather i apologize
for that yeah yeah and
when you do watch it you'll just get
confused because all the men have the
same names they
look the same i tried i watched the
first 10 minutes and i was like is this
all just one man
playing nine different parts the
godfather but with eddie
would be amazing um go ahead sorry yes
so
uh you know massive bestseller at the
time when it came out in the 1850s
uh and was that you not knowing when it
came out or you trying to add a little
bit of stank to
the 1850s 1850s
that's 170 years ago it's a long time
ago that's preposterously long ago
it's not that long can you even think i
mean could they read in the 1850s that's
a silly
they couldn't fly um they couldn't fly
but
a horrible thing about um the uncle
uncle tom's cabin
is that um it so
scandalized people because i still
haven't said what the book is though
it makes me think you've not read it and
you're now just fishing just going
scandal the book is about um
it's kind of sprawling george orwell
called it a good bad book which i think
is perfect
it's it's about a bunch of um slaves and
slave owners in the south
in um the 1840s and 50s and um
i mean it's it's an interesting book uh
and one of the things that really
scandalized people
was that there's this um mixed race um
sort of escaped slave man who's
incredibly hot
and sexy like he is just the most
typical hot victorian hero are there
pictures in the book
not in my copy but um he's just like his
entire
his whole character is just like
incredibly sexy um you know he like
he like stands with a pistol and like
kills a bunch of
like attacks a bunch of um slave
catchers and like protects his wife and
child or at one point that's sexy
he a man protecting his wife and child
is sexy isn't it
get away from my family like that's why
people love taken because the sexiness
of liam neeson protecting his daughter
yes it's same with conair yeah
he just wants to get back to his family
he's
he's got a pet name for that i can't
remember yeah i think the biggest thing
about
hummingbird is it hummingbird yeah
hummingbird what's a great sound conair
aside from nicolas cage's
wig is is it a wig maybe he grew his
hair long
all right is it zander or casper he's
got a funny name
uh steve bashimi not murdering and
eating the little girl
they really make you believe that steve
bashimi's gonna yeah that's my favorite
scene in the whole film and then she's
just going
bye steve bashimi steve bashimi
imagine having that face and not being
an actor p you'd you'd just be terrible
the fact is he's famous
if you're weird-looking you've got to
get famous otherwise it's a tough life
so i'm still trying to get there because
otherwise it's horrible to live with
it's a great film for listeners i was
gesturing at my face not
my wife's face otherwise there would
quickly be a bit of a scuffle
a scuffle a skirmish yeah
on this podcast um harriet beecher
stowe's book
obviously it was a scandal because
people were like you a white woman have
sexualized a black man that is not okay
so harriet beecher still is white
yeah okay you're getting her confused
with harriet tubman very different i'm
not getting a confused with harriet
tubman i just i thought that
there could be two people with the same
first name and i did not realize she was
white
um my sister's called harriet i think
she's white
yes so harriet beecher stowe
got sent this is so horrible she got
sent
a um black person's ear in the post
oh gosh and someone was like i read your
book and it made me so angry i cut my
slave's ear off here
yeah wow really [ __ ] up
i've been thinking this week of uh i
always have
little ideas and i go that could be a
show and i had a show idea called net
good and whether you do a one-man show
about
has the internet been a net good for
things it's a pun in the title
um it's not a joke about cornish
fishermen discussing their
fish catching methods
are that good net good yeah it's not me
describing uh
my mother uh called a net and she always
tells the classic tale about the time
that someone came to the classroom and
said excuse me sir
i need a net and the teacher went well
you'll need to go down to the sports
hall for those
and everyone laughed because she was
referring to my mom you are all over the
place today
i look last night was a difficult
evening
it was a difficult day because i ate
some burgers we're getting away from ben
hur but we'll circle back around to it
the other two days ago i made some
lovely bison gorgonzola burgers for
those of you that aren't familiar with
that
let me give you a rundown on the classic
burger mix you get your burger add in
some milk to denature the proteins of
the beef
that's a new one to me i only started
trying that recipe i love you but this
is so boring add in an egg add in some
panko bread crumbs or some ground up um
crackers saltines if you even got any
panko they still work
and then i'm mixing some seasoning
obviously is this number one
amount of detail of beef and then i
stuff gorgonzola in the beef
make it into a closed sphere flatten it
into
and it's a delicious delicious burger
now
once you've done that so what happened
was i made these burgers they were
really nice you saw how happy i was when
i was eating them you were joyful
the next day i'd put them in the fridge
overnight to keep them i wanted to cook
them again
turns out if you cook something from the
fridge you have to cook it for more time
than you did when the meat was at room
temperature if you were my
student right now and you were telling
me this story i would interrupt you and
tell you that part of your education was
learning how to be more succinct in your
storytelling
look the story ends with me eating raw
meat and being
really rather sick and i consider myself
having somewhat of an
iron stomach which is great although it
did mean that essentially for six hours
of the day
my stomach was just churning around
constantly and i couldn't really do
anything about it
you think when you have bad foods you
can get it out my stomach's like no i'm
just going to keep this in here
until it's neutralized it was i felt
like
my stomach was kettling my protesters
inside my digestive tract um and then
i did a show and i was not looking
forward to the show because i felt
horrible
but for those of you that aren't
performers you might not be familiar
with the concept of dr showbiz
which is a genuine thing and we
discussed this and you've had it
when you're feeling sick you feel i
can't do this you get on stage and
immediately it's like a show must go on
adrenaline rush
that just hits you and you're like boom
like it's like when i really need the
loo before i go on stage i'm like oh i
need a piss but
they're going to call my name i go on
stage i can do 30 minutes of stand up
and i come off stage not even
remembering i needed a week i once
um and the audience have just witnessed
me weave myself on stage that's usually
what happens
you were with me when this happened i uh
i i had some beta blockers right which
you take beta blockers
uh to help with like stress and anxiety
and they lower your heart rate
and i took some beta blockers and then
did an improv show
and it was the worst idea ever because
it turns out that a critical element of
doing good
improv is being really frightened and
anxious and i was just like relaxed
and so people would just like say
something to me on stage and i'd be like
yeah man because improv
improv is yes and alice's was yeah cool
it was really bad
every character you played was just a
chill stoner i just had nothing
to i just was not thinking fast enough i
was just so slow
i loved that i really love that we
should get back to ben hur
we should get back to ben hur after the
advice of a
if you've children me cook it a little
bit longer and b
don't take beta blockers before you do
an improv show
ben hur based on a book called
ben hur or the story of the christ
which i love the idea of the christ
that's brilliant that's how i used to
sign
all of my christmas cards to my family
and my
great aunt did complain to my mother why
has he started signing it christ
because i would put chris t and draw a
little smiley face on the tee because
yeah i was like the the old school
banksy
and then her i thought it was just a
chariot race yeah me too that's nine
minutes of it
and the other three hours and 40 minutes
now i don't want you to be unfair it's
not three and a half hours of jesus
it is it is two hours of like
seriously homoerotic revenge tragedy
very homoerotic but no one told charlton
heston so charlton heston famous
nra supporter i think the nra president
he said you could take my gun from my
cold dead hand
and he's been hurt that was fun so he's
been he's been here and and gore vidal
was the script
doctor one of the yeah one of the
industries he was like okay this this
plot only makes sense
if one of these guys is in love with the
other but he knew he couldn't tell
charlton heston because charlton heston
would have been like outrageous the gays
no
and so instead he only told the guy who
played uh is it messily
masala yeah um and so he told that guy
he was like alright he's a roman
kind of governor of the province of
judea which is where it's set it's like
masala just so you know
you are in love with charlton heston and
you guys dated when you were younger
and so one actor is just being like this
is a straight up like gay breakup
revenge tragedy oxymoron uh yeah
and then the other guy is charlton
heston who's just like
no i'm you know i'm completely straight
it's normal for him to be this close to
my face delivering this line
oh he's looking at me dead in the eyes
for quite a while to be fair my brother
watched this with us and he was like i
don't see it at all
but yeah but he he has straight blinkers
on do you think
yeah i have the opposite where i think
everyone in history is gay yeah
slash goggles is that what it is yeah
anyway um
so so yeah two hours
then nine minutes of seriously awesome
jerry grace
go and watch the chariot race i don't
think it's not like oh you need the
context to appreciate it
just know that the two main guys in the
chariot race uh one of them
is in love with the other and the other
and the first one uh rejected and
know that this film filmed this reel no
cgi
2 000 horses two and a half thousand
horses featured in the film and 200
camels which you know is pretty good but
not as good as the horses mate
and they train though they did all the
stunts and no horses died
that's impressive that's mad they didn't
kill you watch that you're going oh
some horse is getting getting trashed
mate glue geddon
but it's great and then after that it's
another hour
of just the story of jesus christ yeah
and also lepers
and the thing is they really pull out
the leper strand
benjo's wife and daughter get like sorry
ben has sister and mother sister and
mother hey
look incest all women relationships
exactly
um they they get leprosy and the film's
like
oh no they're gonna die you're like well
no because jesus is in the film
obviously that's the end
and that is the end jesus spoilers yeah
jesus gets crucified
and then rain comes and they're cured of
leprosy yeah blood reign
yeah it's the blood of christ yeah which
cures all leprosy
yeah it is it is a lot of jesus at the
end
and you never see jesus which i liked i
think that was i think that was good
actually
it was good because i mean what if he
was really ugly it's that situation he
had to get famous
but we also realized that the life of
brian the monty python film
essentially is just a straight through
parody yeah
because the first 10 minutes of ben hur
is the opening of
the life of brian and the posters are
the same exactly the same posters so it
made us want to watch uh
the life of brian which you should all
watch it's brilliant
i don't like it as much as holy grail
okay cool i think i prefer it but let's
re-watch them and we'll come back to it
they're the two
two great python films the the one after
that was
do they have us what's the meaning of
life yeah with mr creo so in the guy who
eats the waffle thin mint
yeah yeah it's not as good still great
great comedians
um we we we were about a year since um
pandy started pandy times things
you know vaccines are happening there's
in the news this week
there's been a bit of a kerfuffle biden
called some
republican governors uh or accuse them
of neanderthal thinking
yes because they said texas greg abbott
said let's open up
and i think the advice from fouchy at al
is
hey we're vaccinating people but
what happened in europe was they did
this and they had a massive fourth wave
so
maybe chill um and a bunch of governors
have just been like
no party time yesterday there was a mask
burning
on the steps of a capitol building
somewhere really and i saw a video of
um like seven and eight year old kids
being told to drop masks in a burning
oil can
which one seemed very dangerous but the
kids said the cutest thing
what do you say little girl was just
going here you go
mr fire are you hungry and then drop the
mask in i'm like
wow this is adorable if only the
anti-massacres
used these just darling little
six-year-olds one of them
was was like what was that go goes bye
bye mask we don't want you in our world
anymore
adorable now i shouldn't wear a mask
anymore it really has changed my opinion
um if only i could be as cute as that i
think if i was doing it bye bye mr man
off you go horrid yeah really really
disgusting
baby voices really don't work when a man
tries to be sexy like i can understand
that some people like it when a woman is
like
oh does daddy want her it's the second
it's the sexy baby voice right it's the
um
um do you mind if you would give me a
drive to my pilates class
well we watched um for your eyes only
last night which is the james bond film
which features for no reason a storyline
about
i guess like a 16 year old olympic
skater yeah he's like very [ __ ]
in this innocent kind of way she has a
line where she goes
um he thinks i'm still a virgin and
you're like
[ __ ] [ __ ] be a child she doesn't have
anything to do with the plot it's
completely mysterious what her role
in the film is and james bond does not
sleep with her yeah he's horrified when
she tries to sleep with him
she's naked in his hotel room and then
she throws up and he's literally like
get away he says he said before he makes
this joke but he's like i'm gonna buy
you an ice cream yeah
yeah which is also similar to the start
where james bond
kills blowfeld even though blowfeld
offers to buy him a delicatessen
it's a very strange film really weird
really weird
off the rails so yeah the innocent
innocent young children burning masks uh
right so the pandemic's been going on
for a year
which is surreal um it's lasted that
long remember how when it first started
everyone was like all right we're gonna
have to lock down for two weeks
so um so this is how you can tell i
think things are getting back to normal
at least for us i at the start of the
pandemic
immediately bought a pull-up bar being
like well i'm going to be in the house
all the time
it's going to be maybe a month i'm going
to get real buff ting arms and i started
doing pull-ups
as you can see i do not have buff-ting
arms or as you can hear
i do not have buff-ting arms however
this week
i bought a pull-up bar for here it's in
the gym here so
i think i'm going to get started again
because i thought well do i keep my
pull-ups up every day throughout the
pandemic or just do it at the end no
this is the same thing
it's a this was like a tweet that i
remember seeing where someone was like
the pandemic has now been going on long
enough that i had time to get in shape
and out of shape again
yep yeah no totally totally agree so i'm
gonna start getting buff ting and then
you know on the road in two months we're
doing some shows and i'll be like
boom look at those guns um and that's
just because
i'll be performing in a place where they
like guns that was the worst joke ever
he didn't live very well i think he
could have been it had legs it did it
did i
i bailed out i just sometimes you know a
joke's not gonna be very good
and it's fine to admit that you know
some jokes are great like i've been
doing all week doing a great gag
about how eminem has told everyone hey
i think you should all get the johnson
johnson vaccine why is that chris
because you only get one shot yeah come
on everybody
do it subjective
um johnson johnson the bloody mayor of
detroit
you know what he's done they were like
hey here's some vaccines for all the
people in detroit
you're like that sounds like a good
thing and he went sorry is that 6200
johnson and johnson vaccines
i don't want those and they said why not
it's not like we're going to give you
the other vaccines to make them
say that's fine i don't want him so
what's happening today
he says detroit has enough vaccines to
give one to everyone who wants one
currently without the johnson johnson
which i think is [ __ ] because i
think
a lot of people want vaccines right um
he said because johnson johnson is
not as good he doesn't want it
now i'll tell you what's the most
important thing
not dying and all the vaccines
stop you dying one you can't compare
these tests that the test that they did
for moderna for pfizer for johnson and
johnson they were not identical tests
johnson johnson's tests happened like
two or three months after the modena and
pfizer one so it was
when the world had already changed and
all these things it is not as effective
at preventing
a symptomatic covid um it's still
very effective as far as vaccines go and
it stops you dying
would i would i only take it takes one
shot that's much easier
you get it you don't have to fridge it
it's cheaper easier to distribute
um our friend who's a scientist was
talking about how it's unusual the way
we've been
comparing the vaccines because uh with
other vaccines that's not a thing
because scientists don't tend to to kind
of test their vaccines against each like
if you're
taking a you know a flu a flu shot you
don't
you don't compare like which flu shot
you're getting and
kind of think about that because i don't
know it's like it's it's too expensive
to test them against each other in a way
where you could actually decide which
was the best
and uh comparing them apart from that is
apparently
not that scientifically relevant is what
she was saying
um i was understanding drifts of what
she was saying
yeah it's like when someone asked have
you seen that film you were like yeah
they're like do you understand vaccines
basically yeah roughly
basically but yeah [ __ ] buck your
idea up man
i think when people say oh you know i've
got enough for everyone who wants one
no like people people want want vaccines
schools are starting again in some
states
there are teachers who haven't been
vaccinated yet give the bloody vaccine
even if it is
only 66 in fact it doesn't it
it stops you dying let's not
die vaccine news dolly parton got the
vaccine she got the modern vaccine
because she
has she gave money to the university
she's such a baby
she's up there with pope francis you
know yeah well oh gosh you're going to
enjoy some of the news this week about
big old pope
has he done something bad no he's done
something very good of course he has
um the news dolly can you guess
what she sang when she got vaccinated
i mean it's only two dollars is it nine
to five and jolene
okay which one do you think's gonna be
nine to five where's jolene
and what did she sing
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
she did indeed and let me say to the
listeners i didn't that time there that
wasn't edited
that was the amount of time it took for
her to come up with that well done alice
win thanks well done
so that was great the second line was
i'm begging you please don't hesitate
not as good
no she could have put some more work in
on that one yeah she could have but i
still think
uh what a babe that she's doing what a
babe well done dolly
uh more vaccines dalai lama got his
vaccine you know what he sang
no weirdly vaccines vaccine um i don't
think he sang anything no
um but dalai lama has been vaccinated
that seems a bit late for him
i think he should have got it a bit he's
an old bloke
yeah but i guess they think that it
doesn't matter if he dies because a new
dalai lama will show yeah does do people
know this to explain to us about how the
dalai lama is picked because i find it
fascinating his spirit goes into a new
child yeah yes
yes it does which is cool and then
people show up at your house and say
your kid's the dalai lama mate you're
like wow yeah we're gonna take him away
from you and raise him as a monk
when i was 13 i thought i was the
reincarnated spirit of kurt cobain
he hadn't died yet had he um when i was
13. yeah yes he had
died in 1994. yeah okay oh yeah okay
cool sorry yeah how old do you think i
am
she's 76 years old you've been
vaccinated months ago
exactly we can move from tibet to
thailand
now this is a lovely news story a a ship
sank caught on fire and sank that's not
nice chris people survived and
the thai navy went out to go rescue it
and someone gets the binoculars out to
scan it and goes
we've got all the survivors but what's
that that looks like a cat
and there were four cats on the burning
ship and so one of the rescuers says
i'll go save him and he swam out to the
ship and the cats got on his back
and he swam back to the ship which
sounds lovely until you see a photo of
him
during the rescue where these bedraggled
sudden
very scared cats are on his back clearly
clawing him
to tread and his face is just this
massacre like
i'm saving these cats for it they're
bloody painful
swimming with i can't believe they all
got on his back it may have been
one at a time two at a time three years
it's hard to imagine swimming with four
cats on your back unless you had a very
broad back
massive shoulders yeah i'm not entirely
sure that that uh that would be possible
enough to fit them all on
i'm very i'm just very happy that the
cats made it out
yeah and the people as well did everyone
make it out
yes i hope so otherwise this is a really
horrible story yeah no from what i
remember they did
they did would you do that i mean would
you say save the cats
why not because they'd claw my back
thank you very much yeah but
people would say oh what's that scar
like in the ken follow book winter of
the world
one of the characters has scars all down
her back from when she was pushed
through
a glass window of a shop during the
battle of cable street when the police
forced them through the window of
gardner's department store
and she says at the time i thought they
were ugly but now i carry them as a mark
of pride
yeah yeah that's true uh that that
sounds very
mature as a way of dealing with it um i
just think i'm not a very good swimmer
let's be honest
i don't really know how to swim i think
those cats could swim better than i
could
arguably yes cats are quite good
swimmers but yeah tigers can swim
absolutely which is horrible to think
about
i remember being at school there was a
guy in my class who dived into the pool
started swimming but only could move
backwards so
he dived in swam with his arms and just
slowly just butted into the wall behind
him from where he had
dove dived i don't i'm not sure yeah i
don't i don't really know how to swim
i could probably make it out of a pool
if i was chucked in
but you're giving me ideas of how to
dispose of you if that's
we've spoken before about you go on a
walk push them over the cliff or
go down to the municipal baths yeah
absolutely that would that would do it
but um burning shipwreck makes me think
instinctively of the poem everyone in
the victorian era had to know do you
know casa bianca
no although i know that you hate the
film version uh and i'm thinking of
casablanca
it's the same word no casablanca and
bianca and blanca are the same yes but
not the same let me just can i just i
want to google something yeah
i'll do the alice's googling phil story
so when you're cooking a burger the most
important thing is to not press down
too much everyone hates because the
juices will flow
out and you lose the juiciness one of
the advantages of letting it sit
overnight is that i feel that the bread
crumbs and the crackers do absorb the
moisture quite well and you do end up
with quite a moist burger
i i love burgers right i'm to read this
poem to you so this is a pattern that
everyone in the victorian era had to
read
um i might skip some
lines but why because they're just
horrendously offensive no they're not
it's not offensive
it's another poem that um george orwell
called a good bad poem
you you mentioned this good bad stuff a
lot can we just have a brief because we
we mentioned it in a previous podcast
and we didn't really get an experience
so george orwell by the way his essays
are so great i love him he's wonderful
i've always found him very orwellian
so he he has this whole essay about um
he talks about it in a couple different
places
because he calls kipling a good bad
writer but he also calls it that's where
you mention it yeah
so he also calls um harry b justo a good
bad writer
uh it's it's i i think it's a it reminds
me a little bit of
the way people talk about guilty
pleasures where it's like it's something
that is
it's obviously good in that it connects
with a lot of people
but it's also obviously bad and that
it's
bad like can't you tell me that gangnam
style is my ringtone
okay the boy stood on the burning deck
once all but he had fled
the flame that lit the battle's wreck
shone round him oh the dead
yet beautiful and bright he stood as
born to rule the storm
a creature of heroic blood a proud a
childlike form
the flames rolled on he would not go
without his father's word
that father faint in death below his
voice no longer heard
i'm gonna read on but let me explain
what's going on please do there's a 12
year old boy roughly
uh he's standing on a ship that's in on
you know in flames because he tried to
start burning a mask
and the fire spread his father told him
to stay still
and he's waiting for his father to tell
him that he can jump off the ship but
his father is dead
okay he called aloud say father say if
yet my task is done
he knew not that the chieftain lay
unconscious of his son
speak father once again he cried if i
may yet be gone and but the booming
shots replied and fast the flames rolled
on
upon his brow he felt their breath and
in his waving hair
and looked from that lone post of death
in still yet brave despair
and shouted but once more aloud my
father
must i stay while owe him fast through
sail and shroud the wreathing fires made
way
they wrapped the ship in splendor wild
they caught the flag on high
and streamed above the gallant
child-like banners in the sky
there came a burst of thundersound the
boy oh where was he
ask of the winds that far around with
fragments strewed the sea
with mast and helm and pen and fair that
well had borne their part but the
noblest thing which perished there
was that young faithful heart
that's the victorian equivalent of my
burger recipe i think
was it very boring look look i didn't
want to butt in
all i was uh as soon as you said it so
who's that by it's
by a lady called uh felicia humans
okay cool yeah you could choose one of
those felicia he-man master of the
universe
sure oh i missed my chance to do my joke
earlier my ben hur joke
you know it's 2021 it's actually been
they them
come on that's such a [ __ ] joke oh
everybody is brilliant he said it to me
earlier and i was like you shouldn't
because it's just not even funny or it's
just hacking and he was like no
no it's good okay so what i think is
interesting about that poem right is
that so whenever i have my
students study that poem they always
finish it with this look of like
what so the kid just dies and i'm like
yeah because he's an obedient child and
they're like
but that's stupid and i'm like no it's
noble
and that's why you should fight in the
trenches right like that's
that's the uh the culture that they're
that they're living in right i mean
they're soaking in this culture of
doesn't matter what how stupid the order
is go and fight
over the top boys over the top so it
made me think of the fact that spike
milligan
had a a parody of um
casa casa bianca so spike milligan irish
comedian
actor poet um the author of some of my
favorite poems growing up
uh what's the one about like a baby
sardine saw his first submarine and he
asked as he looked through the peephole
come come come said the sardines mum
it's only a tin full of people
isn't that nice that's very good that's
nice so casa b casa bianco was imitated
by spike milligan
and um he just did a version the boy
stood on the burning deck
when saw but he had fled the twit
that he retailed that casa bazonka yeah
that is
i think that shows i i find it
interesting because it really
those two perms together it shows how
much we've changed and i think a big
part of how we've changed is world war
one
um from a culture of of obedience and
honor to a culture of
of cynicism and individualism and i
can't help but say a culture of
questioning authority
yes which has its advantages of course
but although now people are questioning
authority
when they're like what do you know oh i
have a doctorate from harvard yeah but
what do you
know there's that um but i also think
that personally if i imagine like
america going to war with china
i i don't fancy america's chances
because uh china has much more of a
culture of the boy stood on the burning
deck definitely yeah
and definitely you know that's kind of
what you need to win a war yeah
china also has and it's been rolling on
with its new weapon do you remember the
chinese weapon we were talking about
last week no remind me
anal swabs oh yes i wouldn't call that a
weapon well
the japanese embassy think it is because
they've asked china to stop anal
swabbing their citizens
apparently what is china up to when
japanese people have been coming into
china
at the airport they've been told sure
you can come in you do have to let us
swab your butt
and it does seem punitive the way they
discussed it
is um the procedure has caused them
great psychological pain i think that i
mean look i don't want to speak for
other people but i also think people are
bit a bit weird about their bums aren't
they yeah that's true but but japan did
say
no one else does this
china look i'm not going to kink shame
but what's the deal
[Laughter]
so i think the biggest news this week
well two big stories and the second one
will be to do with your pope the big one
has been the
uh the debate around the covered relief
bill which has been
trundling through the house and now has
gone to the senate did it pass it did
pass the senate trillion
1.9 trillion yeah which uh was explained
by republican senator ron johnson which
is
a great name for a porn star um ron
johnson
argued against it by putting out a chart
of the thickness of a dollar bill and
therefore how
high this stack of 1.9 trillion dollars
would reach and how it would get to the
moon and back
if uh it was to be stacked up and that
was his one of his arguments
passing the bill was it would be it
would be too tall a stack
too high and to that i say hundred
dollar bills there you go you've already
right one percent of the size exactly if
you're thinking about it that way
um he's i mean he's also just a grade a
bellend
he extended the they were debating on
thursday
and he used a rule where the whole bill
had to be read out loud
in the senate so the staff of the senate
not even centers just had to read
through 640 something pages
which look i'm going to say if you're
going to pass legislation
you should read it all however the
senate in the past especially
i mean more recently the republican
senate and that's just because i
remember i'm sure this happened in
democratic majorities as well
um would just give the the legis uh
legislation
an hour before the vote was due and it
would be 1100 pages
no one's got time to read it um so you
know
uh but they they did pass it they had a
big thing that the phrase that i liked
this week was vote-a-rama
which i don't sounds quite fun it does
sound fun doesn't it i don't fully
understand what it means but it's a
process by which during the debate
any senator could call for a vote on any
amendment to it
just go let's vote on that and everyone
would have to vote that sounds chaotic
yeah well it was um there was an
amendment for a 15
minimum wage which again has been
splitting people
several democratic senators eight
democratic centers voted against it
well i guess i i think the thing about
it i mean
it sounds to me like a great idea um but
i can imagine if you live in like rural
wyoming and you own a coffee shop you
might not want that
so i think yeah i think joe manchin's
argument he's the kind of main swing
vote in the senate at the moment because
he's
almost an independent even though he's a
democratic senator
he said well look i'm from west virginia
15 is too much in west virginia and
maybe is the case that living costs in
west virginia mean that a living wage
would be 11 dollars per hour and he said
11
hours fine and so the whole kind of
sweeping 15 thing
like well yeah i can see why people
would say why don't you set
a living wage per each state i think
the the people on the left would say you
can't trust
states to do that because they'll say no
it's six dollars an hour
because the minimum wage in america is
so low what is it i
think it's like seven dollars something
it does vary from some state like
california has a higher one
but it's it's shockingly low well it's
it is
it is distressing to think of how few
people
can afford to just like if you think of
like the the kind of
nuclear family uh there's so few
families where
one man has a man one person has a job
and the other person
takes care of kids and that's enough for
everyone to be happy
would have been in the 50s right you've
got your i mean it's the ideal of white
suburban
i think that's the yeah that's the
american dream but i think what you have
to look at is who had the american dream
and it was a pretty small proportion of
the population
really maybe that's unfair i guess i
just mean it certainly was not a dream
that applied to
it was not a universal dream um but
it it feels as if it's gotten much
i often think this is a sort of sort of
sinister flip side to feminism
is that as women have come into the
workplace everyone's been like all right
great so now you have
two people working whenever they have a
family so
you can pay them both less if that makes
sense
yeah good point alice win
yes i'm i'm a searing attacker of the
feminist cause
yeah so one of the democratic uh
senators was
kristin kristin or kristen i don't know
uh i don't particularly care
uh kristen's cinema and she voted
against the wage rise
even though a few years ago she tweeted
hey
if you work full-time on minimum wage in
my state you only make sixteen thousand
dollars
which is what nothing for a full-time
job yeah that is your
labor is valued at sixteen thousand
dollars she said we need a fifteen
dollar minimum wage now
um and then she voted against it and
people said hey what about this old
tweet
and she said said you're all being
sexist
um no one would talk to about this this
is uh sexist
however she and sadly anyone listening
will not see but i will reenact how she
voted no
okay she walked onto the floor patted
mitch mcconnell on the back
walked up to the roster where you give a
ro and the roll call the votes on these
are often done with a thumbs up or
thumbs down
she's pretty cool and roman and she
did this
for those of you listening kind of like
a mic drop yeah
mic drop that's a perfect description
thank you darling um and walked away to
cheers and claps
and so it didn't pass um and you know
these
a lot of people are upset about that i'm
sure a lot of people are very happy
about it as well
just come on guy i mean we discussed
this with your
brother who i think keeps us in check
sometimes because he's uh probably a
little left
a little less left than us he said he
said
well if you've got a big company you
should have to pay that yeah the
argument is
a small mom-and-pop coffee shop yeah
maybe they that's not sustainable for 15
a thing but i guess the thing is that
you would what
could happen is imagine if like amazon
starbucks etc have to pay
15 minimum wage and mom-and-pop shops
don't
i could imagine there'd be something as
if amazon and starbucks would
struggle a bit more no that's not what
i'm saying i actually think in some ways
the mom and pop shop might struggle a
bit more because
fewer people would want to work for them
um
a politician in the making yeah we'd
have to get rid of all of these episodes
of podcast people would trawl back
through them
it is i think it's much harder to be a
politician nowadays because
you know 20 years ago people would ask
you did you smoke dope at college
they'd go i didn't inhale whereas now
people just trawl back through
everything and go oh you said this
i think nira tandon didn't get wasn't
put forward for a nomination for biden's
cabinet because of tweets that she had
done
admittedly they were just tweets being
like mitt romney could suck my dick
or in the equivalent of that right um
yeah it's it must be much harder now
well i think
i think that we're probably among the
generations which
don't really know how to like i suspect
that in 25 years
everyone all those young people who are
growing up with it will just know
internet
etiquette like in their bones and
they'll look at the way we were using
the internet when we were teenagers and
just be like
what the hell was wrong with you i hope
that teenagers now are more cautious
although that holocaust
tick-tock trend would suggest not i mean
it's from seven or eight months ago but
what uh what a
day that was yeah for those who don't
know it was a tick-tock trend where
alice will describe it much better than
me because she's
uh well-meaning
where basically a bunch of teenagers
were like we want to make sure that the
holocaust isn't forgotten it's very
similar to when
all those like beauty vloggers for black
lives matter painted half their face
black
and white like look we stand with you
without realizing
that they were doing black things right
so it was actually exactly like that uh
basically these
these like tic toc teenagers were
basically like um
so that no one will forget the holocaust
i will make a holocaust themed tick tock
where
there were a couple different songs that
they used but basically there were two
main ways you could do your holocaust
tick tock one
was um you're like you're like you know
it's
you know 2000 it's 2020 and then
suddenly the beat drops in the song and
suddenly you're wearing like striped
pajamas and you're like i'm in the
holocaust
don't forget the holocaust guys that was
one and then the other one was just
um you would kind of like hold like a a
bowl of soup or something and be like
it was 1939 i was making a stew
then the nazis came now i'm in heaven i
don't really want to go into the the
sort of morality of the holocaust big
talks
but what i will say is that they suggest
that teenagers today are still making
um unwise internet decisions it's almost
as if teenagers
are still to fully mature and don't
understand the consequences of their
actions
it's possibly like that i think what i
found sort of befuddling about the tick
tock videos was just that they were so
well met like when
when people people just kept being like
i just think no one should forget these
stories and now that i've made this tech
talk
of course will not be forgotten raised
the awareness it was important i mean
the thing is
it is a different time because in the
past you could make a mistake and
no one would even think of it right like
that boy who stood in the burning deck
now people would just
mock the [ __ ] out of him because he died
come on mate you've stood on that deck
you idiot that's not a good comparison i
thought it was a very funny joke
but uh as always i am not a professional
comedian
let's so the second news story hello
second news story
pope big old papa papa pope
um peppa peppa means pope in it
how's france tell me you're i'm on
tender hurts wait do the photographers
that follow him around call himself the
paparazzi oh yeah yes
yes it's a good joke um
so he do you know where he went for his
holiday this week where he
buggered off to iraq did he yeah he did
he's in iraq right now
he's in mosul it's you're right i mean i
think
it's not an abduction it's not like
islamic state rocked up
i guess i just mean vatican city we're
taking this pool like what's his is it
like because you said on holiday that
makes it sound as if he's
gonna be i don't think it was a glib
intro to the bit
yeah i was riding high off the paparazzi
failure absolutely
the joke before um no he's gone he went
to iran
and then he went to iraq to heal
tensions to you know rock up
as a christian leader to an islamic
region
and go hey guys sorry about the crusades
he definitely didn't say that and and
just be like let's
let's heal and he went to mosul which is
a city destroyed
pretty much entirely by islamic state
led prayers
i saw some videos people there are very
happy to see him
your mum showed me one of all these
little girls greeting him dressed up in
wedding dresses
which was pretty weird well they might
be they might have been more like i mean
like in some like in spain like when you
get your first communion you wear a
wedding dress yeah yeah a little
little white white dress they were it
was very very sweet they weren't burning
masks
um and so the pope has been there and by
all accounts it's going really well
he's people loving it just quite i just
think he's got the right
idea most of the time i think when the
dalai lama dies someone should go to the
pope and say
you're also the dalai lama mate it
doesn't have to be a child he could
reincarnate into the pope
um and then the pope's suddenly gonna go
all catholics my edict
you're now buddhist because the pope is
infallible but only when he says he's
influenced yeah he has to
he has to clarify he's not infallible
all the time
um no what a babe i i really wonder
i don't know like i don't i i love him
in this way where it's not like i want
to hang out with him i'm just glad he's
around why don't you want to hang out
with him you wouldn't invite him to your
dinner party no i wouldn't invite him to
my dinner party i think
i mean i think he'd be fine i think he'd
do well in my dinner party he's just not
top of my
um list i don't think he um
i don't think he seems like he's fun
what what gives you that idea i think he
seems um like noble and true-hearted
you think you'd tell him a joke and he'd
just go
i think he would kind of i think the
dalai lama would laugh at your jokes the
dalai lama i think
quite famously is funny and has a good
sense of humor oh really
um yeah i don't know i mean i look i'm
this is all absolutely speculation
because my entire
sort of worshipful relationship with
pope francis comes merely from reading
the headlines and not the articles on
twitter about him
so it's it's incredibly uneducated but
um i get the feeling that he would smile
at you kindly
so that you didn't feel as if your joke
had been a failure but he would not find
it amusing
um is that not just because i think it
would be in his third or fourth language
also that yeah because when i perform in
some countries
their english is is great but it's not
as nuanced enough to get
maybe a joke that i've done that's
pretty you know pretty high brow
like that paparazzi and people will kind
of smile and clap
and be like hahaha yeah i got that
where there are other countries where
the english is just perfect like norway
audiences in norway will applaud just to
show off the person next to them i
understood that
they're doing that person applauded and
they're doing like shakespeare laughter
right yeah
yes shakespeare laughter oh my gosh for
anyone who doesn't know alice will break
down shakespeare shakespeare laughter is
when you go and see a shakespeare play
and there are a bunch of people who just
laugh very
smugly and proudly when they get the
shakespeare jokes and they're like
that fool's riddle was not bad i think
is it henry v
part one there's loads in french and
there's a whole scene in french and the
main
joke is that they say a word that sounds
like the c word
or they say idiot in french which is the
c word in our language
and so i think i think they say kong oh
yeah right
like shakespeare was using that as the c
word
and so the audience like you laugh at
that
however and i i knew that was coming i
read the place i was like this is gonna
be funny when they say that
also because you're like are they gonna
say it this is [ __ ] what rude
but throughout the whole scene in french
people were pissing themselves
at little french gags and i'm like none
of y'all speak french
i say over one of my pe teachers at
school
it was just such a good bit he would
just drop in french phrases
just done in his accent so we're like
all right lads everybody gather around a
say a voo a say
today we're playing and i really liked
that
it was very fun to me i feel like i also
had a teacher who did that
but the other way around with english so
no no no no as in like although yes i
did have my sister do that
was at a foreign school in paris and
there was a nun
who used to say we must [ __ ] us
[Music]
we must [ __ ] us i think that is a joke
that the pope would
smile at i think he'd smile kindly
yeah there are so many jokes about nuns
it's like very transgressive to you know
two nuns are riding or
riding bicycles to church and one says i
haven't come this way before the other
one says oh no must be the cobbles
there's this thing about all these these
nun jokes it's because they're so pure
and then we have this idea of them being
filthy
yeah well it's classic isn't it it's uh
undermining
undermining it is in james bond last
night it ends with
a real undermining thing and under mine
is a relevance is to do with thatcher in
a film that was out two years after
thatcher was elected
it ends with like a caricature of
thatcher answering the phone
to who she thinks is james but it's
actually a parrot that's talking to her
and the parrot starts being like give us
a kiss and margaret thatcher's like oh
james also she's washing up while doing
it and her husband dennis thatcher is
trying to eat the food she's cooking and
she's like
no she's like swatting him away yeah
it's not super chris was like
i don't think they'd do this if she was
a boy
guys i think there's some sexism
involved in this james bond film
oh a slight hint of misogyny but
that's the only time in any james bond
film a prime minister has been
an actual prime minister has been
portrayed or named it's true
lovely segway for our last news story of
the week and this will combine with the
breaking news um it's a new story from a
few days ago a
pastor in missouri or pastor
one of the difficulties being british in
america and there's very few
is words that i say that they don't
understand because to them
pastor and pastor sound the same when i
say them
i'm talking about a religious leader not
i have this with my students where um
because i pronounce wagner wagner
and they are american and they pronounce
him wagner and i'm like no you guys
you guys have to say wagner one second
that sounds exactly the same
oh you saying that they have to
pronounce well yeah if you're american
and you're like
oh i love the music of wagner people are
going to be like
sorry you have to say i love the music
of vogue i think most people would say
you mean wagner also i think you say i
love the music of wagner people do just
give you a slightly weird look
yeah i mean they are teenagers do
how do you feel about the jews yeah for
those of you that don't know wagner was
an anti-semite uh and also
loved by hitler and the nazis now i do
think we should clarify
that uh wagner is obviously writing a
lot before
hitler and he was a romantic nationalist
and
i don't think i mean in the 1800s you
don't know what romantic
nationalism is going to lead to right so
i think it sounds lovely
the phrase romantic nationalism yeah
well it's about it's
what basically it's um the rise of
nationalism uh happened a lot in the um
late 1800s you have all these
revolutions and countries becoming
nations and um
you know uh various different groups
rebelling against their oppressor
states and wanting to be their own
nation and
so romantic nationalists uh and there in
every country
would um would go and try and write
these like romantic
versions of their of their nation right
so
um in germany you have like the grim
fairy tales and wagner writing up all
these you know beautiful legends
um and i mean france has this england
has britain has this um
it's all over the place and yes wagner
for sure an anti-semite he said
of mendelssohn who was a jewish composer
who's really good he was like well yes
but he doesn't have any soul
does he it's like all right well chilled
out chill out um
but i think you can't say for sure that
he would have been
pro the nazis because obviously the
nazis are much later
the difficulty is the nazis and as a
performer
if a group of people loves me i do have
to give him love back but
uh stop really hoping i don't get beard
taking the proud boys circuit everyone
starts showing up to my gigs with black
and yellow polos
i guess you i think you do deliberate
jokes to try and alienate people
who you don't want to like you
that is possible yeah that's why i do
all these jokes but ah people who are
six foot four and above could [ __ ] off i
don't want people taller than me on my
show
tall idiots um so the
uh the pasta the pasta the pasta yes uh
should i say pasta i don't like it it's
not your accent
yeah because i'm i'm northern and we
shorten our a's we say aft
after rather than after much as this is
all very interesting i am curious about
the story you initially wanted to take
so one of my favorite things to do is
split long and short a's so i love
saying masterclass
or masterclass i think it's really fun i
love that
yeah when people say visa or mastercard
if i had a mastercard which i don't have
visa i would say
master no i'd say mastercard doesn't
work that way mastercard
mastercard mastercard on that subject of
northern accents manchester united beat
manchester city 2-0 today ending their
21 match
winning run ah absolutely amazing
bragging rights manchester city is still
going to win the uh
the premier league this is where you
need to hang out with your male friends
i know
please talk to me about football please
and not american football
british football can you tell me this
story so he gave a sermon that then went
very viral
because he explained to women
that men were made by god to look
they're always going to look at other
women and it's your job
to be a sexy wife for him
look maybe he goes maybe you can't be a
trophy wife like melania and he puts a
picture of melania
but you could be a participation trophy
wow
try and look like melania and this guy
look
again i think it's not nice to shame
people because of how they look
however when they are saying something
stupid about how people look
this guy's a [ __ ] uggo this guy the
only reason he became a pastor was
because otherwise he wouldn't be famous
enough to be that ugly
he he said this and people were
boreous uproarious and so the breaking
news was that he's now taking a leave of
absence
um but just i kind of wonder why people
still do that
it's 2021 i don't know that's the phrase
that everyone you can take with any year
come on
it's 18. it's 12 15. stop
where are you we've signed the magna
carta there we go yeah she knows
she knows what years are going on okay
so when he was writing that
what did he think was do you think he
thought people are going to go oh yeah
we need to start putting on slovenian
accents
i think he uh i think he probably
thought
this is a subtle way to tell my wife she
used to get on the treadmill
i don't know i think he probably you
know he believed in in the roles of the
sexes and he felt that women were
forgetting their role and men were
getting their i'm sure that
i'm sure that all of his sermons are not
always
being like women stop being ugly i'm
sure he has other sermons where he's
like men
stop not being men you know what i mean
like he probably just has this very
old-fashioned view
of gender roles it's funny how whenever
something really sexist happens in the
news chris is always like can you
believe it
and i'm like yeah look i studied
feminist anthropology
and one of the reasons i got quite good
marks in it was that
during the the classes i was the only
boy i just realized if i prefaced every
answer i gave with well as a man i'd get
points from my tutor who who would go
well done chris it's good to hear a man
say that
i just would be like well that's a man i
think women should be treated equally
she'd go
well done you see every other person in
the class all female just look at me and
just go
oh we hate you so much um one day i took
it too far i said well you know what i
actually think women should be paid more
than men she went whoa chris that's too
far we just want equality that is
every single piece of news that has been
what about the book this week
okay there was a part that's breaking
news i guess last night
some students at boulder university had
a bloody rager and i showed the video to
alice
before she saw what she went this sounds
like this is going to be a a woodstock
type of event 600 students maybe more
gathered for a big fireworks party they
tipped over a car
the police showed up the students pushed
the police back
as you can tell all very privileged
white students um yeah and and obviously
like not uh
it's we haven't lost anyone from covert
i'm sure that if we had we would have um
pretty strong feelings about this party
uh but i
i do think just all of that aside
yeah i bet it was a good party people
were standing on
on the roofs of porches the the snapchat
video i saw
was was like it has this voice of this
guy going that's what i'm talking about
i was like yeah that's kind of what it
would feel like it it's been a while
yeah i mean if you're like 20
and it's been a year that's a 20th of
your life
yeah and more than that really because
you can't really remember it i think
probably you're like seven so it's
it's just such a huge chunk of the
problem is i have a very poor memory for
things that i've done and things that
have happened so for me
this has been a year it's been a hundred
percent of my life pretty much with a
couple of pin
pricks of memory showing through like i
think you went to menorca when you were
a child
yeah i did i used to play metal slug for
100 percenters ago
in the arcade and i was bad at it but
i've got loads of 100
coins from taking back all the trolleys
at the airport and getting the coins
so that's your life now it's just it's
just quarantine plus metal slug that
would be a great life
metal slug makes up for it metal slug is
an incredible game i
would urge you not to tell me more about
that
well i won't tell you about metal slug
but what i would like you to do
is to tell me about something you've
learned this weekend yes um i will tell
you something not that i've learnt this
week because i don't feel like i've
learned anything this week that i want
to talk about
but um i will tell you the story of
sirlon fal
um how are we spelling that
l-a-u-n-f-a-l-l
i don't know how i thought it would be
spell but it wasn't that way really yeah
lon fal um so cellophile is a um a
medieval romance by someone called
thomas chester
although i think he didn't come up with
it right um i think the earliest
sterling foul story is probably from um
marie de france who was writing in the
12th century
but um thomas just started writing later
and he writes the sort of
uh british version and this is the story
uh it's one of my favorite medieval
romances i really like it
so sirloin fowl is a night of the round
table
and he's a very good knight um but it's
really expensive to be part of the round
table and he's very very generous and so
he basically runs through his entire
inheritance in about a year he like
gives all these feasts etc um and then
he suddenly has no more money and he
can't be a knight he has to sell his
armor
so he retreats to the countryside and
he's crying in the woods one night
when a beautiful fairy woman comes up to
him and is like i have fallen in love
with you from afar and i'd like to be
your secret lover
and salonfell is like great i'm
definitely up for that
um her name is lady triamore and she's
beautiful
and she says i will give you everything
you need and want in your life
but on one condition you must never
reveal to anyone that you are seeing me
that sucks because it's like when you
have a girlfriend
and they say i have to keep the secret
from my parents
and so you want to tell everyone i've
got everyone was like you don't have a
girlfriend you're like oh yeah i do but
i can't say he must have been devastated
he'll be like so long fell
lonely lonely virgin he's like i'm
[ __ ] a fairy
i can't say it was very similar to that
and so
he's having you know great sex with lady
triamor
she has i mean she gives him so much
stuff she gives him a purse
that never empties always has coins at
the bottom of it she gives him a
beautiful white horse she gives her
money instead of army she gives him all
sorts of stuff everything he has now is
gorgeous
and so uh he's having a great time and
he returns to camelot
um for a feast and um when he's at
camelot
he looks so handsome in his beautiful
armor that lady guinevere queen
gwenevere i mean queen guenover does not
come off well in this story
queen guenever is very attracted to him
and um basically hits on him
and he's like no thanks and she's like
outraged so the next morning she says
salonfell tried to rape me
and um salonfal is like
lol why would i rape you when i have a
super hot fairy girlfriend cause i'll
try them all
why did you do that exactly so the
second he says this
all of his armor melts away and his
horse disappears and his his magic purse
full of money is empty and
uh he's lost it all right he's betrayed
lady trimor
and meanwhile they decide to put him on
trial and because it's
the middle ages um they're like look
if you can prove that your girlfriend is
prettier than queen gwenevere
will believe that you were not trying to
rape gwenevere i think that's fair
um gwenevere meanwhile is like there's
no way she's prettier than me
i bet my gray eyes that i'm more
beautiful than she is
does she have multiple eyes is she that
way she has to clarify
so she uh she hangs out they're hanging
out by the gallows he's all like ready
to be
hanged and um they're waiting to see if
his girlfriend's gonna show
up and then this beautiful woman arrives
on a horse
and she's gorgeous and everyone's like
salonfield you're saved and he goes
that's not her
that's her servant because in in
romances there's a
there's a tradition of um like
you how good looking you are relates to
your rank so like
if you have a really beautiful servant
girl that must mean that you the queen
are
extra beautiful because you're going to
be proportionally better looking than
your serving girl does that make sense
okay yeah so the sermon girl shows up
and and uh loren files like that's not
even her that's just her serving girl
and then like
the serving girl's mistress shows up and
she's really hot as well she's even
hotter but she's not he's like that's
not that's
the next maid um and more and more of
these beautiful women keep showing up
and start on fire keeps being like it's
not her she's not gonna come
and uh he's must not have any couples
then um
[Music]
and so he's ready he's getting ready to
die and then
suddenly lady triangle shows up and lady
trimor is
so beautiful that king arthur turns to
gwenevere and goes
she's prettier than you i definitely
don't think he tried to rape you i want
a bad husband
and uh lady trammell goes gently up to
gwenevere and blows on her eyes and
gunniver goes blind
and then salonfell gets on the back of
lady tramwar's horse and their ride off
into ferry never to be seen again
wow and that's the story of salonfell
that's great so guinevere loses our eyes
yes so her name is gunveer
if you take the eyes out of gwynevere
thought that joke about a minute and a
half ago i was like come on chris
come on chris you got it she's gonna
alice is gonna say whatever lose the
eyes he didn't say it
doesn't have any eyes in it what the
ease
g-u-r
no i reckon with all those medieval
names you can spell it however
that is true it depends on yeah sure
that way but it's guanavera it's
g w e n v e
r e there's a character okay so there is
one i in it
ugh it goes g-u-i-n-e-v-e-r-e
that is the story of siloam vel thank
you very much i i enjoyed i enjoyed
hearing
hearing about all that it is time for a
freestyle of the week's news alice has
the things that we spoke about
on that phone she's going to throw them
at me during the beat i am going to make
up a wrap on the spot
inspired by them over this pretty
banging instrumental which i'm going to
turn up
and alice uh you are going to in a few
seconds
give me the first suggestion let's get
this cracking and turning
yeah this is good that's what i'm
talking about give me that first
suggestion
the pope's in a ruck yes he is
[Music]
look at him all fancy that a big white
hat and the man's in
iraq asking everybody how are we gonna
heal
rolling around and rocking a pokemobile
he's like yeah
cross your fingers be hopeful rocking up
maybe give a prayer in mosul the most
high guy at the catholic church
everybody's like wow you'll be healing
the hurt we be needing
a fancy man let me get to senate cause i
got a plan my name's ron johnson
on display i'd like to say everybody big
rj
got a shout out if you wanna debate
everybody get bored everybody does hate
even people in this party disagree
they're like well fractures in the gop
why we gotta vote i wanna relax i've got
a country house i wanna fly right back
why are you whipping out why you're
wasting the time
if you wanna mix up your little song
lines like dolly
never say sorry go in there maybe in a
car in a lorry
get in the madonna they're in her upper
arm she's like yeah this song will work
a charm
vaccine vaccine vaccine
vaccine i'm begging you please don't
hesitate
not as good on the second part there but
she'd be cured
she be inoculate let me get it up there
won't make calm down
i don't get it a lot up my butt with a
chinese anal swab like three
inches or maybe five every japanese
citizen
when they arrive gotta get down on all
fours
oh i need some lube can you add more no
we gotta swab you anally
maybe you could go back travel overseas
don't come here
closing down the borders is not what i
ordered talk about symbols in the hi-hat
they're on the track you can rescue the
thai cats
four of those little kitties on the ship
that's 37 lives you can save in a click
wait oh
i got my mental mass wrong 36 apologies
yeah gong
gong for gang switching the a they
[Music]
hear the little instructions your dad
said i gotta stand round
oh please papa i can hear all the flames
incinerate more
roaring i feel i'm going to die the
flames touch my skin
then i fry crying and the bee ends there
keep it going
a little bit yes i'm aware i thought
that it was meant to be
christ dies than the cured of the
leprosy it was
too long by a lot only interested in the
chariot it was amazing
of course it was how many horses died
none
cuz yeah thank you
i mean it's good you had a podcast where
we have discussed a film with a lot of
camels and a night at camelot
the joke i thought about uh earlier that
didn't do because i think it was good
enough but
riding high off the wrap you can get
away with any quality i sometimes think
a lot of our marriage is you thinking of
jokes and not saying them
i think so yeah yeah i think that's a
good advice think
before you speak and i'm going to pass
that advice
yeah hey freestyle rapper well done
thanks we're actually working on a
double act where we just go bounce to
bounce back and forward with rhymes so
get ready for that
it's an absolute pleasure as always
talking to alice wynn it's a pleasure
talking to you christian
thank you and it's a pleasure having you
lovely people listen if you've enjoyed
it please do
spread the word share it with a friend
tell them that this is where you get all
your news from and it is
a valuable i'm increasingly convinced
that this is not a good way to get your
news well some of the people have been
commenting saying this is all i get my
news from now
that's concerning that's what i want i
want to be i mean this is
he's that that [ __ ] melty angry guy
who
is from infowars and he gives everyone
their news and they listen to him and
they go yeah the
sandy hook massacre wasn't real was it
not real my god
well if you listen to alex jones that's
what you think um
so yeah thank you very much for
listening do leave a comment uh
if you've got any any tips any advice
any uh not criticisms i don't want to
hear any criticism
yeah mate and i'm going to anal swab you
as well alice if people want to find out
more about you where can they go
they can find me on instagram at let
them eat books with underscores instead
of spaces
you can find me on instagram at chris
turner comedy that's all for us
from me from her to you goodbye